welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and one division still set to
scramble our brains with multiverse
witchcraft later this year has revealed
what could be its biggest update yet
reports that Evan Peters might be
playing a mystery role in the series Oh
Peters of course played the mutant
Quicksilver in the x-men movies Days of
Future past apocalypse and Dark Phoenix
last year remember that which we're all
in the Fox Marvel movie universe in the
comics Quicksilver Peter or Pietro
Maximoff and his sister Wanda Maximoff
Scarlet Witch are the children of
magneto now the Marvel Cinematic
Universe introduced their version of
Pietro Maximoff Aaron taylor-johnson
immediately killed him off in Avengers
age of Ultron all while sidestepping
that mutant and Magneto connection to
avoid legal issues with Fox at the time
which was then a separate studio with
their own Quicksilver that is no longer
the case
Disney owns Fox and all of its marvel
mutant properties and we've just been
waiting to learn how exactly Kevin Feige
and the MCU will reintroduce the mutants
the rebooting them or quietly merging
them pretending Deadpool was in the
background the whole time or by going a
crazy multiverse route and this news
might be proof that they're doing just
that now it is not yet confirmed that
Evan Peters is playing Quicksilver
specifically the sources I've seen
suggest his role may be a smaller one in
one division and that he was just merely
spotted on a set for the show some have
also speculated that Evan Peters could
be playing an adult version of Wanda's
son the mutant speed or that if they
wanted Quicksilver to factor into the
show's plot they would just resurrect
the Aaron taylor-johnson version of the
way they've resurrected Paul Bettany
vision that's necessarily true like the
MCU may plan to introduce speed but
they'll probably do it with a younger
actor for a future Young Avengers
stories probably wouldn't cast another
actor famous for playing a speedster
Peter's casting feels deliberate to me
because if he weren't playing x-men's
Quicksilver why include him at all in a
Marvel superhero story with the title
character being this characters sister
now sure Evan Peters is a very nimble
actor he can play all kinds of roles but
so are dozens of other actors that they
could go with that wouldn't confuse the
[ __ ] out of people Peters is best known
and most valuable to the studio as
Quicksilver which was one of the few
elements from the later excellent films
that Fox Marvel actually pulled off
better than
so you did and a role that he played as
recently as last year though was barely
in dark Phoenix and not a whole lot of
people saw it but still running through
that kitchen and Days of Future past
remains Evan Peters biggest on-screen
moment of his career we like hearing a
rumor that Hugh Jackman was playing a
small role in the New Mutants and
arguing no they're just mean he has to
be Wolverine could be a gardener I mean
sure Hugh Jackman would act the hell out
of a gardener but he's in Wolverine
those hedges are getting trimmed with
adamantium you don't cast an actor
famous for a role in adjacent property
for a role anyone could play it's one
division Quicksilver is one of max
mouths brother is MCU counterparts dead
and this story appears to be about
Wanda's unstable grip on reality
while Aaron taylor-johnson could play a
resurrected Quicksilver I don't think
the Quicksilver role would simply be a
matter of resurrecting a dead brother
the show is not opening the doors to the
multiverse one division is gonna break
down the walls of reality Evan Peters
Quicksilver if true is a sign that one
division intends to cross over the MCU
into other previously separate film
franchises to retcon them into the MCU
multiverse everything we know about one
division is pointing in this direction
clues and the promo footage and pointed
to Wanda's pregnancy and children Billy
Caplan wicken and Tommy Shepard speed
signaling to many that one division will
indeed adapt the House of M storyline
for the comics in which one doe resets
reality again again trying to preserve
her hypothetical children and eventually
all of reality within without mutants we
have speculated that this could manifest
as genre flipping across various sitcom
themed realities or even Wanda
performing a bewitched style blink
resetting the MCU with mutant friends
but again assuming Evan Peters is
playing Quicksilver even a brief one
episode cameo would tell us that one
divisions multiverse will be a meta
gateway for the MCU retcon II and past
ultimate franchises as parallel
universes I got a theory for how this
could work there's a lot to break down
here sometimes I can run out of gas what
I'm trying to sift through all these
details one way I keep the juices
flowing is with some help from bang
energy
every Kanna bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and has zero calories
yeah it's great there's over 20
different flavors to choose from one of
those great flavors is birthday cake -
the cake is great I get everything just
need cake flavored steak cake flavored
pizza cake flavor
nachos cake flavored pie cake flavored I
guess it's just cake look there are
mornings when I was up late the night
before writing the full movie breakdown
I'm really dragging a can of bang energy
house pick me up so that I can just like
power through the rest of what I got I
do check out bang on Instagram you can
get 25% off your order at bank - energy
calm when you use the code new rock
stars 25 there you can buy cans of bang
energy including their sweet tea and
keto coffee flavors you can also get
clothing fitness supplements all kinds
of stuff to be your best bang self there
are zero artificial colors in this thing
they also got a beverage that's called
stoked
it has a broad spectrum hemp extract if
you're down for that
thanks again the bang energy for
sponsoring this video get 25% off at
bang - energy calm using the code new
rock stars 25 okay
imagine one division introducing one a
maximov in a state of mental distress
after the losses of her brother Pietro
and her lover vision her breakdown
triggers her psionic powers that she
used to project illusions on the
Avengers in age of Ultron but inside her
mind this time causing her to flicker
through reality's similar to dr.
Strange's multiverse acid trip or even
the trippy Collider imagery from into
the spider-verse
vision lives on in her mind as a
projection since her powers were derived
from the mine stone and it was that link
that allowed her to destroy the mine
stone visions head an infinity war so
ghost vision tries to help want to
stabilize her mind reminding her what
normal reality looks like first using TV
sitcom tropes but then that pop culture
thought train jumped the tracks into
another parallel dimension like for
example Wanda could wake up in a dark
haunted psychiatric facility when she
discovers is the Ravencroft Institute
the place where the new mutants are
trapped I'm not saying those actors will
appear in Wanda vision but if it's the
same setting it would link the cinematic
universes but next her consciousness
drifts into Josie's bar from the Netflix
defenders universe
further down on the bar Nelson and
Murdock are trying to convince a new
defense attorney to join their firm
Jennifer Walters she-hulk and then
finally one is consciousness drifts to
the halls of the x-mansion where she
briefly crosses paths with an alternate
version of her brother who gives her the
strangest look as he's running in slow
motion pastor now this wouldn't
necessarily mean Evan Peters Quicksilver
would rift with Wanda back in the MCU
reality could be as fast as Quicksilver
his brief cameo in Deadpool 2 but it
would be just enough of a signal to
viewers that the previously separate
cinematic universes are now connected in
a multiverse and it would leave the door
open for Wanda's mental breakdown to
collapse all these parallel realities
into one and dragging the certain
Newtons from the Fox Marvel Universe
into the MCU like Deadpool maybe
Quicksilver maybe Colossus and it would
establish that counterparts in alternate
realities look different from how they
would look in the MCU because Evan
Peters and Aaron taylor-johnson
different facial structures there right
and it would justify other mutants like
Wolverine being cast as an actor who's
not Hugh Jackman it just Wolverine
another reality was Hugh Jackman this
one
it's a henry cavill county reeves
whoever we want complicated a bit but
it's no less complicated than DC's
crisis on Infinite Earths crossover
event or any given episode of Rick and
Morty see multiverse logic these days
has really been the norm ever since
we've diverged into the darkest timeline
back into 2015 or 2011 whenever Sinbad
went back in time to rename the
berenstain bears no point is be very
vigilant of casting news for any of
these x-men associated actors in MCU
projects because it could tell us which
of the Fox x-men get rescued by one to
maximov's
supermarket sweep through the multiverse
and which of them will be forced to
consider their final chapter their
Kleenex
and be sure to watch the upcoming
episode of rogue theory in which I'll
expand this theory to further explain
how Wan division and the multiverse
could be used to save daredevil and
bring in Charlie Cox Matt Murdock into
the MCU now I know the Netflix defenders
verse is kinda MCU but we need to get
this guy in the Kevin Feige PG a MCU
proper we're of interest Tower is
allowed to appear in the background join
our future MCU watch lungs on discord by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
new rock stars and be sure to vote in
our poll for our next free watched
series which you can get a greater
singing as a patron follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at EA vaz follow
new rock stars and hit the subscribe
button for breakdowns of everything you
love thanks for watching bye
[Music]